hey youtubers is Charlie Happy
Thanksgiving
I hope you all had a chance to see the
Doctor Who 50th anniversary special
since so much of the show's history is
incorporated into it I thought it'd be
fun to do an Easter egg hunt this video
is going to be part one of that be sure
to subscribe to get part two I'm going
to post that on Saturday they've also
been a lot of recent reports about Peter
Capaldi maybe being the fourteenth
incarnation of the doctor so I'm going
to do a video about that next week - so
here we go all these Easter eggs are
listed in order of chronological
appearance in the special first the
title sequence from the first season of
Doctor Who in 1963 the sign totters Lane
was where William Hartnell hid his
TARDIS after fling gaol free with his
granddaughter Susan Foreman I am Foreman
was a Gallifreyan monk living on earth
he formed a traveling show using 13
different aspects from all of his
regenerations
and even cross paths with Sarah Jane
Smith and the third doctor later Ian
Chesterton was one of the doctors
earliest companions in the very first
episode he later became a science
teacher at coal Hill School in the 1960s
w Coburn is a reference to Anthony
Coburn who was the writer of the very
first Doctor Who episode an unearthly
child no more is written on Clara's
blackboard the clock reads 5:15 p.m.
that was actually the time of the first
episode of Doctor Who airing on
television the motorbike car riding the
motorbike into the TARDIS is actually
something from the Doctor Who TV movie
Clara closes the doors by snapping her
fingers this is something that only
River Song used to be able to do
cocktails on the moon there's actually a
unit base on the Moon Man by Elizabeth
Shaw Osgood scarf so this is the Fourth
Doctor scarf given to Osgood by her
mother Kate Stewart given to Kate
Stewart by her father given to her
father by the Fourth Doctor who
mysteriously looks just like the curator
of the National Gallery the doctor
hanging outside of the TARDIS as it
flies over London is a callback to the
11th hour Matt Smith's very first
episode as the doctor the 3d painting so
the 3d painting is actually an idea that
they took from Nightmare Avedon from the
fourth doctor's run in that episode they
take things that freeze them in time a
weapon with the conscience so this is a
reference to a Douglas Adams story life
the universe and everything it was also
an idea they were going to use for a Tom
Baker Doctor Who movie back during the
fourth doctor's run sentient Time Lord
technology is also a call back to Idris
the doctor's wife - bad wolf
so Billie Piper isn't actually playing
bad wolf
she's playing the living conscious of
the moment device but her appearance is
a nod to the super goddess Rose Tyler
from series 1 the clockwork so the
clockwork of the moment is a nice
reference to the repair bots from the
girl in the fireplace the horse the
horse is a nice nod to Arthur David
Tennant's horse also in girl in the
fireplace Alon Z is tenants doctors
famous call to action but he said that
it actually means two different things
one it's French for let's go and two he
said it during the end of time before he
died and that it was a word of
consolation to the soul on times of need
so think of it as like tens spiritual
chicken soup I'm not English David
Tennant is actually one of the Scottish
doctors just like Peter Capaldi's going
to be tenants costumes so the outfit
he's wearing is from series two but the
actual physical cost to him that he wore
on the special is one that he took home
with him after he finished Doctor Who he
actually owns a copy of each piece of
clothing the tent ever wore and because
costumes are so rare from that time he
actually had to use some of his own
clothing in the special the timey-wimey
detector it was actually first used by
David Tennant in blink later Tennant
jokes at Matt Smith's doctor for using
the term timing why me with the John
Hurt doctor saying that he has no idea
where he gets that from Saigon so Zygons
actually appeared in the first original
unit story from Tom Baker's Run terror
of the Zygons I think that they decided
to use unit in the episode first as a
plot device and then consequently
decided to use Zygons is a nice callback
to that episode funny the Tom Baker also
ended up as part of that plot - I'm
going to be king so Elizabeth and tent
actually did end up getting married and
since the doctor has technically not
died yet Matt Smith's doctor has a
legitimate claim to the throne of
England the five ish doctors stone
statues so in Peter Davison's parody
documentary the five ish doctors the
surviving classic doctors try to get
into the 50th anniversary episode
hilariously and end up becoming figures
underneath the white Claus pretending to
be statues the Blowfish so the Blowfish
were actually creatures from the episode
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang on Torchwood the Fez
so the Fez shows up a lot of times all
over the episode but originally it came
from the second doctor's run in the
episode evil of the Daleks which is
actually one of the most famous lost
episodes
the Cybermen painting in the background
the Clara's looking at is a call back to
the original Montez design Cybermen from
classic ooh overcompensating Sonic's so
the joke Tennant makes is that Matt
Smith's doctor is overcompensating with
a flashy ER Sonic
because regeneration is a lottery
implying the twelve did not get the luck
of the draw but after watching the
prequel night of the doctor we know that
regeneration does not have to be random
codename Proma 70s or 80s this is
actually a reference to two different
things
one they did chroma restoration a lot of
old Doctor Who black-and-white episodes
and then the 70s or 80s is actually a
reference to the Third Doctor's years
which were supposedly supposed to be in
the 1980s but since they were filmed in
the 70s a lot of 70s references bled
into the episodes incorrectly I think
there's three of them now so Kate
Stewart answers there's a precedent for
that she's talking about the first
anniversary special it was for the
Doctor Who 10th anniversary called the
three doctors the black archive so the
archive was created with the help of the
second or third doctor and has been
visited by Sarah Jane Smith Martha Jones
and it's basically like units version of
the Gallifrey and time vaults the wall
of fame so unit keeps tabs on all of the
doctors incarnations and his companions
so almost everybody from Doctor Who's
past including the doctors and all of
the companions are somewhere on this
wall Captain Jack's port X manipulator
so unit took it off of them after one of
his more recent deaths it's hard to
guess which because after his most
recent death and miracle day he actually
used a vortex manipulator to travel
offworld so that's it for the first half
of the special there are so many Easter
eggs part two is going to post on
Saturday be sure to subscribe to get it
if you thought there was any references
from the first half of the special be
sure to post them in the comments too
since it's Thanksgiving and I have a
little extra time on my hands I'm going
to be doing a game of Thrones Season 4
preview and a Legend of Korra book 3
video on Friday so you will definitely
have something to watch while you're out
buying stuff right now click here to
watch my review of the 50th anniversary
and click here to get that part 2 video
I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post the video on Saturday thank you so
much for watching happy Thanksgiving
high fives I'll see you guys tonight
you